[Música]
que estamos pensando la persona que se
encuentra en esa situación ahora mismo
ellos también condiciones que tú y yo
conocemos condiciones que ella ha
conocido su vida entera tanto físicas
como emocionales pero en 8 minuto y
medio se van a encontrar en una realidad
totalmente diferente una donde no saben
qué es arriba y abajo simplemente no hay
donde moverse a 27 mil 600 kilómetros
por hora es lo normal ni donde si tú
deja caer algo simplemente no se cae se
queda flotando delante de ti
darme cuenta de que la persona que yo
también en televisión en ese momento que
a cuestión de minutos se iba a encontrar
en otra realidad totalmente diferente
fue lo que a mí me interesó en este
ambiente entonces los equipos que hay
detrás de ellos también tienen que
enfrentar con problemas y procesos
reales sistemas que se tienen que
desarrollar para que esto ocurra
no importa que si tú está en marte en la
tierra aquí eeuu en europa en donde sea
las necesidades que como humanos tenemos
son las mismas para tu ser eficientes
estar saludables tu necesita dormir
comer sentir seguridad necesita tener
los procesos para resolución de
problemas detrás de lo que tú te vayas a
enfrentar y eso te da la seguridad de
poder trabajar eficientemente dentro de
tu ambiente simplemente cuando estas
condiciones no se dan naturalmente ya
sea en un ambiente donde no hay agua no
hay oxígeno de forma natural se
necesitan crear sistemas y procesos que
hagan esto artificialmente con ayuda sea
de sistema de tecnología del propio
humano que tenga que tomar actividades
diferentes para hacer que esto esto pase
y sistemas que no consideran la
necesidad de un usuario de forma
completa o sea que no se diseñan
pensando en una necesidad como algo
multifacético como algo que no ocurre
solamente aislado simplemente no van a
satisfacer esa necesidad en su totalidad
o sea que va a es que hacer lo que de
verdad se debería de cumplir para
considerar una necesidad de su totalidad
se necesitará considerar tres cosas
el quién el dónde y el adonde el quién
habla del usuario el usuario es quien
tiene la necesidad pero también cuál es
esa necesidad cómo se ha cumplido esa
necesidad anteriormente y qué pasa a ese
usuario si esa necesidad no se cumple el
donde habla del contexto en el cual es
usuario se encuentra cuáles son los
recursos que tiene a su disposición
cuáles son los obstáculos que se
enfrentan y cuáles son las cosas los
otros usuarios que también se afectan
cuando tú cambia un sistema o implementa
algo nuevo y el adónde habla sobre la
proyección cuál es la tecnología
alrededor de este sistema que existen
que pueden tanto afectar como impulsar
ese sistema que pueden ayudar a la
persona alrededor de este sistema y
cuáles son las repercusiones que cuando
implementamos un sistema que no es
sostenible cuáles son esas repercusiones
y dentro del sistema que tiene
o sea si tú piensas en un sistema y lo
implementas de forma que no es
sostenible cuáles son los efectos que
esos pueden tener hacia ti hacia el
ambiente y solamente en general que no
se cumpla lo que se debió cumplir
soy que el mejor ejemplo que enseñar
cuando un sistema no se cumple una
necesidad no se cumple de forma completa
que un ambiente donde se tuvo que crear
sistemas desde cero porque si no su
usuario no puede existir en su totalidad
sea físicamente la persona no puede
existir en este ambiente si no se
crearon procesos de crear agua proceso
de crear oxígeno de controlar la
temperatura y todos los sistemas que
usted se puede imaginar que hoy en día
aquí widgets por delante no lo podemos
comprar en este ambiente simplemente no
sucederían si no existieran esos
procesos que lo hicieron pasar
entonces la estación espacial
internacional existe a 400 kilómetros de
altura de aquí o esa órbita a esa altura
y existe como un ambiente y hogar hacia
que los astronautas existan y vivan y
entonces ahí se estudia el largo tiempo
el efecto de largo tiempo que tiene la
microgravedad en el cuerpo humano
entonces esos sistemas son muy
importantes porque así tú puedes ver si
tú creas oxígeno como existe aquí tú
puedes ver la diferencia en cómo existe
una persona que está en microgravedad o
sea no gravedad y una persona que existe
aquí entonces como él cambia la
regulación de respiración y el ciclo de
sangre etcétera
entonces uno de sistemas vitales de la
estación el sistema de recolecta y
filtración de agua se coge los residuos
humanos sea el sudor si los astronautas
deben subir y entonces se filtra y se
vuelve agua potable ahora se filtra a
algo mucho más limpio que cualquiera de
nosotros en nuestra vida ha venido se
los aseguro o sea que eso no es problema
pero esto es uno de los aspectos más
importantes que existe
y el resultado de considerar esa
necesidad básica como agua es de forma
completa es que ahora los accionados de
tienen no solamente agua para beber pero
tienen agua caliente y fría para
complementar sus otras necesidades
también y acá como de exploración o sea
los otros experimentos que existen y
también para recalentar su comida porque
el agua caliente funciona para eso sin
porque la comida se manda al espacio
generalmente deshidratada se considera
el contexto o sea el donde está
estacionado está porque se usan los
residuos líquido que existe dentro de la
cabina a casi a un 90 por ciento y se se
considera la proyección porque a un
costo de 18 mil dólares del libro
demandar algo al espacio y con los
planes dentro de la industria que sean
que la estación funcione como método de
aprender cómo se puede ir más lejos de
órbita terrestre baja esto simplemente
no es un sistema viable para cumplir esa
necesidad de la astronauta cuando uno se
va más lejos o simplemente no es un
se ma viable por el costo entonces es
muy emocionante cuando tú ves toda esta
compañía nueva compañía que están
creando tecnología más accesible para
que las personas puedan hacer
experimentos en el espacio sean
estudiantes sean profesionales que tal
vez hacen esto como hobby sin embargo
cuando no se crea un sistema o se
desarrolla una industria de forma
sostenible lo que se crea es una
eficiencia en el sistema en general y no
se se impide el desarrollo más adelante
por ejemplo qué pasa con todos los
proyectos esos satélites que se mandan y
simplemente se quedan ahí no se
desintegran
eso es una foto una foto de en 1957
antes de que se mandara es por mí que el
primer satélite ruso es lo que deben lo
punto blanco
estos son los fragmentos que existían de
forma natural y simple sin embargo
después de que nosotros empezamos la
exploración espacial este ha sido el
resultado en 2017 hay más de medio
millón de fragmentos que se pueden medir
y millones de ellos que no se pueden
medir entonces lo que significa que en
la expresión espacial como tal se
desarrolla es emocionante se ha hecho
más fácil pero cuál es la sostenibilidad
o sea qué pasa con eso cuando tú ya no
soy ni siquiera podemos salir a explorar
o el riesgo es mucho más alto de lo que
existía simplemente por los sistemas y
procesos que hemos estado abarcando
si la necesidad que nosotros tenemos
dentro de la estación son la misma en
cualquier lugar que tengamos puede ser
alguien aquí pueden ser la misma en
donde sea porque lo proceso que
utilizamos si ya vemos como industrias
de forma tangible se ven como esos
procesos
los resultados de ese proceso entonces
por qué no utilizamos este proceso aquí
o sea porque no utilizamos la forma de
pensar de en el usuario pensar en su
contexto y pensar en la proyección en el
cual ese sistema va existir para
desarrollar sistemas más inteligentes yo
no creo que sea eso algo ilógico pero
por ejemplo cuando se cierra una calle o
se pone de una vía una calle que
anteriormente era de dos vías qué pasa
eso con las personas que transitan esa
calle qué pasa con las personas que
existían alrededor que viven por ahí qué
pasa con la calle alrededor cómo se
afecta el tránsito alrededor de eso se
hizo la comunicación de que esa calle
ese cambio de esa forma o la regulación
para acompañarla eso es un tipo de
preguntas que para cumplir una necesidad
completa tú debes de considerar
entonces este tipo de pensamiento yo no
creo que solamente pasa en la industria
espacial por ejemplo si los gobiernos
son aquellos responsables de hacer
sistemas públicos servicios públicos
pero ese usuario del gobierno están
trabajando con tecnología que no es
integrada no es fácil de usar o
simplemente no funciona no sea no se
comunican a sí mismo como les afecta a
los servicios que ellos pueden que
pueden producir
por ejemplo una de las una compañía
fundada por una dominicana trata de
centralizar esos procesos que los
gobierno están tomando y ponerlo de
forma intuitiva
y así poder hacer que las personas
dentro del gobierno tomen sus decisiones
en base a información en base a que
puedan entender cuál es la proyección de
que esa decisión que están tomando va a
tener
por ejemplo dominicano también es
sostenibilidad tres ejes que busca no
solamente concientizar pero tomar acción
con las con los procesos que ya nosotros
tenemos el día a día de consumo de botar
basura y como como nosotros tenemos la
responsabilidad de tomar a cargo sobre
eso que ya hemos hecho para que no se
siga ese desarrollo y respetuoso y
responsable de nuestra parte y porque
hay donando de eso es porque yo creo que
aquello quería en el privilegio de
identificar una necesidad lo deben hacer
de forma completa y es su
responsabilidad de trabajar para cumplir
que esa necesidad sus bases simplemente
para el desarrollo para el usuario y
simplemente porque es la responsabilidad
que cada uno tiene
[Aplausos]
[Música]